the problem with wanting to be friends
with your child is that that's not good
enough because as a parent you're not
less than a friend you're far more than
a friend you're someone that's gonna be
in the child's life for the duration of
your life with any luck
you're a long-term island of stability
in a sea of turbulence and the child
needs that far more than then he or she
needs a friend
parents need to be courageous because
they have to let their children go and
make mistakes you have to let your child
fall when they're learning to walk they
bump themselves up against the world a
lot and you don't want to do any more
for your child then you absolutely have
to and it means that there's a certain
amount of detached harshness that has to
go along with your love and compassion
so you have to stand back and let your
child stumble forward towards mastery
today's parents are terrified of their
children because they're often afraid
that if they intervene in their lives
that they'll make a mistake and that
that will be irrevocable and you have to
have the courage of your convictions
when you have children and you have to
understand that if you do make mistakes
that you can learn and you can be
forgiven you don't have to be a perfect
parent although you should aim up with
your children parents are terrified of
making mistakes and that means that
they're terrified of being parents and
they and that stops them from being
parents
[Music]
you